storage sheds provide a home for things
that don't belong or fit in the house
they're made from plastic panels
embossed with a woodgrain making one
starts with the computer design once
they have a plan machinery rolls into
action high-density polyethylene plastic
flows into a big mixer an automated
scale measures out the correct amounts
of ingredients as they enter the mixer
they add a cooling accelerant and a
colorant to the polyethylene pellets
thorough mixing ensures that the final
product will be evenly colored and have
structural integrity a vacuum pump moves
the blend out of the mixer and through a
network of pipes along the factory
ceiling the pipes deliver the
polyethylene mix to a machine called a
blow mold er it will blow melted plastic
into a two-part mold the blow mold melts
the plastic into a tubular shape the
plastic emerges hot and malleable in
manufacturing lingo this is called a
paracin the mold closes around the
paracin as little needles Pierce and
inflated the paracin swells against the
walls of the mold taking its shape
the mold embosses a tread design on one
side an original automated clamp
extracts the hollow panel at this point
the plastic is partially cured but still
hot when the panel is ready to be
handled a team trims the overflow next
the team cuts slots and tabs that will
be used for assembling the floor panel
to the walls now it's over to another
blow molding machine this one creates
roof panels complete with cedar shingle
detail once again they trim the flesh
and grind it up to make new panels very
little polyethylene goes to waste
the next machine moulds door panels with
a tongue-and-groove beadboard block a
worker randomly pulls panels off the
production line for testing she verifies
that the assembly holes are the right
size she also ways and measures the
panel to confirm it meets specifications
another member of the testing team dabs
gel onto the panel in various locations
this gel allows an instrument to measure
the thickness of the plastic once the
panel's passed the tests it's time to
pack up the kits it takes up to three
hours to assemble this plastic storage
shed
however it's a lot easier than building
one from scratch and in the end you have
a place to store things